- All I can say,
is mug life.
This is gonna be amazing!
- Josh, you're confused my friend,
I'm a winner, you root for winners, dick.
- [Josh] True, very true.
(upbeat jazz music)
- While I'm getting detoured,
let me create some clarity for everybody.
The excuses in the comments
section are laughable.
Everyone's trying to justify
why it's not profitable,
while you watch a 30 minute YouTube show.
People value
their time, when their time is invaluable.
I love that.
Where's that Little Lou?
Yeah, I don't think he
realizes how far along we are.
Oh.
(phone ringing)
There he is.
Hello?
- Let's go, let's go.
- [Gary] You woke up within
the last three minutes, right?
- We slept in!
- [Little Lou] Yeah, why?
- I just wanted to confirm that.
The best view, D-Rock.
Listen, entrepreneurs follow me,
a lot of people need
an extra thousand bucks
for their startup.
Like 90% of people are
gonna do this on the side
to try to help build their
side actual business,
and this is actually gonna
become their business,
'cause they're gonna
be like wait a minute,
I can make a hundred thousand a year.
♪ Let's go ♪
♪ Getting back running up ♪
- [Gary] Hey Siri, call Little Lou.
- [Little Lou] Hello.
- Yo.
- [Little Lou] We're good.
- What's your ETA?
- [Little Lou] 21 minutes.
- All right, we're 13 minutes.
Did you watch the episode?
- [Little Lou] Yes.
- How'd you love it?
- [Little Lou] The best part
was the old woman cut in.
- The what?
- Stone wall.
- [Little Lou] The other woman cut in.
- Wow.
- I thought the best part
was when Tyler just shows up
on the pins out of nowhere. (laughing)
All right, I'll see ya in a little bit.
- [Little Lou] All right.
- [GPS] Your destination
is ahead on the right.
- [Gary] It better be.
- [Mike] There he is.
- Stop calling me, Mike.
- That's a good job, Little Lou.
All right, the first garage sale,
let's see what happens.
Do you have any coffee mugs, hi.
- [Woman] No.
- No coffee mugs?
- No, no coffee mugs.
♪ Fuck being friends ♪
- Right here.
♪ Fuck being friends. ♪
- [Gary] Good, you have any video games?
- [Man] Video games?
Not Super Nintendo.
- [Gary] All video games.
- Let me see.
- Thank you.
- The key is sometimes to ask when
you don't see anything, right?
So this sale didn't look good,
but I looked at the man's face and I said,
"Do you have video games?"
I liked what I saw.
She didn't like it, she's out.
She's gone, she saw nothing.
- You know what, man.
- What's up, brother?
I'm gonna have to look for 'em,
they're downstairs.
- Yep.
If you come back in like an hour or so.
- Done, yeah, thank you so much.
He's gonna dig for them,
come back in an hour, that'll
make some good content.
- All right guys, just real quick,
wanted to interrupt the episode
to let you know that we
have nine different designs
for the lower thirds that you'll
see throughout the episode.
They're numbered.
We would love if you would
vote on your favorite,
so that we can use that
moving forward in different episodes.
Now back to Gary and the mugs.
- This one looks active and big.
Ooh, this looks good.
Let's go boys.
- Oh wow, this is big.
Everyone out.
(upbeat guitar music)
What do we see?
There's a train.
That's what you think it is.
- [Mike] I'm not positive,
but that's an RTL train.
- [Gary] Can you do better on the trains?
- [Woman] 25 for those at least,
'cause my son said there's like,
a lot of money in that box.
- [Gary] How much are these things?
- [Woman] $3.
- [Gary] Would you 20 for this?
- My son's not here,
he's in.
- Can you call him?
He's heading the chair.
- I'll call him.
- Thank you, brother.
- [Woman] Call him, said
daddy would you take 20?
- Call Dad.
- There we go, voice.
- There's a customer that
wants to know for the trains,
can we do it for $20?
- [Dad] That's fine.
- Yep it's fine, Momma!
It's fine, Dad said.
- For 20, okay.
- Thank you, thank you so much.
Thanks for calling, brother.
Oh boy, big start.
All right guys, right off the bat,
I mean you know what about
Thomas the fucking Train,
we've established in.
(boinging)
But this is the wooden
stuff, the whole set.
This is a monster, there's
real stuff in here.
Oh, there's some other,
this is gonna be a big deal.
I'm fired up.
As you saw, we negotiated hard,
the kid called his dad,
- Hey dad.
so I'm pumped.
- Gary?
- Yep?
- Oh my god, dude in Verona.
- [Gary] I'm garage sailing.
- Hi I'm Katie,
nice to meet you, hi.
- We live down the street.
- I'm a huge fan.
- Thank you, man.
Holy crap.
- Yeah, thanks.
What are you doing here?
- [Gary] I'm garage sailing.
- Really?
- Hustling baby, flipping.
That's amazing.
- Yep.
- Guys, we struck early.
Thomas the fucking Train, again.
Thomas the Train, they
wanted 30, got it for 20.
Little Lou great job,
looking it up, we saw
something comped at about 100,
we'll figure it out.
These hurdles are real legit.
- Bang, Mike.
- Hitting it off the bat.
Let's go, let's go.
I will forever love that kid right there.
Right there, that kid, that kid,
for calling his dad.
She thought 25 was gonna be the bottom,
she was wrong.
(laughing)
What's that, whoa there it is.
- [Mike] Some stuffed animals.
- Let's go, whole crew.
All right here we go,
garage sale number four.
♪ Everyday I think it ain't you though ♪
♪ 'Cause being me is great ♪
- [Gary] Can you do two for this?
- Two for all of it?
- Yep.
Sure.
- Thank you.
- I'm dying to look this up.
All right, we struck
again, we did some plush.
We got a little Sprout.
I know this character, we'll
look it up in a second.
We got the little Ty spider,
we'll look that up in a second,
and this huge god damn red
dragon, we'll look it up.
That's such a good piece of content.
Oh baby, the Ty purple spider, ready?
All day 12, no tag right?
- [Mike] No, there's a tag.
- There's a Ty tag?
- [Mike] Yeah, oh yeah.
- No, no, no.
- Oh right.
Not the other tag.
Eight to 10 bucks all day.
Paid two bucks for all three,
and here's the results.
♪ Crazy but it's true ♪
♪ Rock 'em poor boy I got no ♪
♪ Got ya wine ♪
♪ Mugginess on a dry coke ♪
♪ Let it be as good as Simon ♪
♪ Wish there was no ♪
♪ Oh baby going loco ♪
♪ For the price I'll go coco ♪
- Actually.
Bang this out quick.
Good morning, how are you?
How much is this thing?
- [Woman] I was gonna sell
the whole thing for $5.
- [Gary] Would you do three?
- [Woman] Sure.
- I just picked up
something from Nickelodeon,
Little Lou's gonna do
some homework right now.
I think they're Agronauts, or Segronauts.
All right, I just struck big.
This is the little part of it,
but this is the little
part of it, the submarine.
It's a Nickelodeon show
with these little guys,
I just don't remember what it's called.
But we're gonna look it up
and I'm gonna let you know,
but I picked it up for
three, she wanted five,
she didn't get it.
She didn't get it.
(laughing) That's the best part
of the whole show.
It's gonna be a huge score,
I can tell you right now,
the Aquanauts submarine
is gonna be no joke.
Call it 20 minimum.
- [Boy] Do you need help?
- [Gary] I sure do, I need to buy
a lot of lemonade from you.
- [Boy] How many lemonades?
- [Gary] I'll take one.
Thank you brother, how much is that?
- [Boy] It's usually one.
- [Gary] $1?
It's one fifty if you buy a cookie.
- [Gary] I don't want a cookie,
but I'm gonna give you 20,
and you're gonna give me a 10 back.
I'm gonna pay 10 bucks,
'cause this looks real.
- Wow, what a tip.
This looks like real lemonade.
- [Man] That is, that's awesome.
- All right?
- Thank you.
Thank you, brother.
- [Boy] You played for?
- [Man] He could easily.
- [Gary] You east!
- [Little Lou] I used to.
- [Gary] It's true.
You know what a revolving door is?
- [Little Lou] All right,
get the fuck outta here.
(laughing)
- Did you find it?
Yeah that's it, how much is it?
- 10.
- No!
- Per shield.
- God this is, no.
Oh, I lost.
- [Mike] And a couple figures.
(slow bass beat)
- I can't believe,
that the submarine, I thought
that was gonna be monstrous.
How are you?
- Good morning!
- Good morning.
- Would you do one for this?
I think it's got a price of two.
Thank you.
This is amazing.
A retro Cosmos hat.
I mean, this is the jam right here.
Cosmos, baby.
Cosmos.
This is awesome. (laughing)
Cosmos hat, that's amazing.
I'm gonna wear that bucket
hat to the game tomorrow.
- [Little Lou] Left here.
- Whoa.
- [Little Lou] Go in,
go in, there's a light.
- I wanna say that's here.
It could be like, coming up.
- [Little Lou] Now, we're
come up the category.
- Well, it's the context Lou, it matters.
- Understand, I get it.
- Here we go.
All right, there's stuff going on here,
I like what's happening here.
This guy's directing.
- How are you, sir?
- Good, how are you?
Good, this is all sold except
for the kitchen table.
- No problem.
Everything else going back chairs,
all the way through the whole house,
and the basement, and the
back shed, outside, inside.
- [Gary] Oh, all of it.
Okay, we're in the person's house,
and all I can say,
is mug life.
This is gonna be amazing.
♪ You coming on a way
financials looking nice ♪
- I have to learn Christmas.
- How are you guys doing?
- Great.
- How much are the mugs?
- A dollar a piece.
- Great.
- [Gary] Where's the
basement, I love basements.
- [Man] Underneath the house.
(laughing)
- No shit, Sherlock.
♪ I just double down in the new vest ♪
- When you get in the house, it gets good.
♪ Type of money made me wanna two step ♪
♪ That's right I be on the moon next ♪
♪ Stop going up like two X ♪
♪ That's a fast flip like suplex ♪
- Hey Instagram, I'm in
somebody's house randomly.
Swipe up to learn why.
Stay with me, stay with me.
Instagram what's up, it's Garyvee,
I'm in some person's random house.
Swipe up and find out why.
Ray, one more time.
Hey Snapchat, you wanna make some cash?
Swipe up why I'm in
somebody's random house.
Do you need some help?
- [Woman] Yeah.
- [Gary] Here, give me that.
- [Woman] I mean technically,
I'm working the sale,
but if could help me anyway.
- I got you.
- Thank you.
- [Gary] Where do you want this?
- [Woman] Outside, please.
- [Gary] You got it.
♪ You'll be all such look ♪
- Oh, boy.
I have to learn Christmas.
I have to learn Christmas, man.
God, I gotta learn Christmas, god dammit.
God damn Christmas.
Gotta learn Christmas.
It's so obvious that
there's so much opportunity,
but I don't know anything.
I just don't know Christmas.
♪ That's funny hell yeah ♪
♪ Fucking right ♪
♪ I wanna sip on Sprite ♪
- Christmas.
♪ Tears what I consume ♪
♪ My whole clique it all black ♪
♪ We are thugs ♪
♪ Tell my ex bitch give me space ♪
- Old yearbooks, they actually sell.
I'm about to see some old yearbooks,
some weird playing cards.
- [Man] I want my wife to come down.
There you go.
Give me one, two, three, four, five, six,
so give me 10 even.
God, try and barter me down.
- I'm going to.
- Pencils of Promise, I
was gonna tell you 15.
- Could you do five?
- Could you do no, could you do eight?
- Let's do it.
- Love this man.
(laughing)
- Thank you, brother.
- Now, did you want large bills?
- No, whatever's good,
whatever's best for you.
- Good, you're getting all quarters.
(laughing)
Had I known I was gonna be on video,
I would've dressed up a little bit.
- You look great.
- [Man] The hat didn't do great.
- The hat's amazing.
- There you go.
- [Man] Do you want a bag or something?
- [Gary] That would be amazing, actually.
- [Man] Wait, we don't have any.
- [Gary] (laughing) Fine,
then I'll just carry upstairs.
- [Man] What do you expect for $8?
- I get it brother, no bag.
- Put those in there.
Do you want me to bubble
wrap all of your mugs?
- [Gary] I would love that.
- Well that's not gonna happen here.
- [Gary] And a bow tie?
Beautiful, thank you so much.
- [Man] Do you want that?
Take it, it's yours, I
want you to have that.
- [Gary] You're very nice.
It's great to see ya,
- Ciao.
thank you so much, ciao.
- Bye, guys.
I hope this glass is worth something.
The free glass at the end could be huge.
As long as I don't get hit.
That's got a crack in it.
I can't wait to look
up, this is just weird.
I love old yearbooks.
Yeah, we made some swipe
up ads, Little Lou.
I'm literally like, I'm
in some stranger's home,
swipe up and find out why.
That's the one, Mike,
I'm dying for that one.
Please be something,
that has a chance to be 60
for no reason, or a dollar.
What's that?
- It's like five.
Five?
- Yeah.
Okay.
(sighs)
I screwed up, but watch
this gangster weave.
Paid 50 cents for this,
it goes for 12.50.
Guys I just picked this
little mini card set
for 50 cents.
Most of you would've past on it, I didn't.
It's worth 12.50.
I see some stuff that
might catch our attention.
(upbeat electronic music)
Little cold here in Verona,
and I don't mean the weather.
I gotta go back to the house.
I think, I mean that ornament's 10 bucks!
There's a hundred of them down there.
- [Mike] Oh really?
- What about the yearbooks, Mike?
- [Mike] You really
think they have a shot?
- I think they have a shot.
Could be some mug life here.
How much is the mug?
Harley Davidson, I've been
seeing the Harley Davidson
T-shirts go for a bunch.
Gonna try it.
Gonna try it, never done it before.
Would you do five for the T-shirts
and a few mugs, great.
- Sure.
Thank you.
- [Woman] Hard bargain.
- [Gary] Yeah I'm tough,
do you have a five?
- [Woman] Yeah.
- Come outside, D-rock,
we got something to talk about.
All right let's see,
picked up two mug lifes,
this Mickey Mouse is legit,
Mike hold this, Bronx zoo.
Little Mickey Mouse, but
here is the big score.
Five retro, vintage
Harley Davidson T-shirts.
I have a funny, funny feeling about this.
I've been looking at clothes,
I've been thinking about clothes,
and I struck on these Harley Davidson.
I just have a good feeling about it.
Let's see what happens.
Garage sale
canceled. (laughing)
Hold on, we're definitely
taking a picture.
(somber trumpet music)
(upbeat drum music)
This is not gonna be good.
I'll be out in a second.
How much is this doll?
- $10, sold.
- $10.
- [Gary] Yeah, it looks it.
- [Woman] It's at least 50 years old.
- [Gary] It's scary as shit.
- [Woman] Yeah, no kidding.
- [Gary] Yeah. (chuckling)
- [Woman] It is.
- [Gary] I know.
No wonder the kids were tougher back then.
- [Woman] Yeah, exactly.
- Take care.
We gotta get back to that house.
- [Mike] Not to that shops.
- I feel like something
has to break our way.
Mug life.
25 cents for Big Mouth.
Some mug life, it's a vintage mug.
I'm mug luffy.
I mug life it.
Yo, we found a rare Big Mouth mug.
- Whatever Big Mouth is, we got it.
- Mug life, hold on we gotta see it.
- Mug life.
- Mug life, mug life mother fucker.
- [Mike] Of course is that.
- [Gary] Who's this guy?
This guy feels like our competition.
- [Little Lou] Yeah.
- [Gary] I feel like I
should smash his car.
- Crush your enemies.
See them driven before you.
- He's competition, definitely.
He's from Pennsylvania,
he's not fucking around.
People complaining about no
garage sales in their town,
this guy's coming from a different state.
I need a big score right now.
The big score's sitting in that house.
- [Mike] Ornaments.
- Boxes of ornaments for a penny,
and I'm sitting around here like an idiot
looking for pelican mugs.
- How close?
(upbeat drum music)
Have a great day.
All right, picked up a keep sake bear,
I'm excited about it,
paid five, a lot for me.
Picked up a lolli though, free lolli.
(slow electronic beat)
- Garyvee!
- What up?
- [Man] Side hustler tick, what's up man?
- [Gary] What's up man, how are you, good.
How are you?
- [Man] Good, nice to
see ya, nice to meet you.
- [Gary] Nice to meet you.
- [Man] Should've known you were gonna be
out and about this morning.
- [Gary] 100%.
That's awesome.
- Thanks, man.
Real pleasure.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
I feel like 'cause he knows who I am,
it's gonna tarnish the purity of the deal,
so we're outta here.
All right, looks good,
let's get some stuff.
Christmas is killing me.
Christmas.
I love mug life.
It's mug life 'til I die.
Little Peanuts Hungry
Jacks, which is Australia.
I just literally saw
Hungry Jacks in Australia,
which is the Burger King of Australia,
that could be rare.
Peanuts Hungry Jack, Maxwell House.
Maxwell House, great to the last drop,
and three Elvis mugs.
Five mugs for two bucks, mug
life mother fucker, mug life.
There's stuff up there too,
right there's one there, huh?
- [Little Lou] There's
another one there, too.
- I like what I'm seeing, in both places.
- [Mike] Entering a thrift shop.
- There's a thrift shop?
But it's only Tuesday and Saturdays.
- [Little Lou] Seven until two.
- Be careful.
See what happens here.
Gonna pass on the yard.
Take care, guys.
- Bye.
Let's just take these and go crazy.
Lou, let's just buy those and
drive them to the next sale.
It's been a little bit of
a struggle here in Verona,
we've been doing some mug life,
but this is not last week,
we're not hitting.
But this is what the great
part about this game is,
literally we're rolling
up on something right now,
and anything could happen.
But so far Plyer, Little Lou,
have not been bringing luck.
How much is the Coca-Cola truck?
- I'm gonna say three.
- That's really cool.
(slow piano music)
We still haven't been able to top
the Thomas the Train buy,
which was the first thing.
This has me excited, as long
as I don't break any of these,
these old yearbooks.
Oh, look at this!
Look, there's like a note.
Look at this.
- There's a love letter in here, Mike.
- It's love letters.
"Dear Jimmy."
- "This is a final note before I leave.
There's other things I wanna tell you."
Oh my god.
"The first thing's naturally
the most important,
and that is this.
I'm gonna call you Friday night.
I'm not too sure of the time,
but it will be sometime between."
- "Six and eight."
- "If you really care
enough, you'll stay home."
Oh my god.
- "Promise to try and make it."
- We should go back and
sell them that later.
- This is incredible!
- "Please, please stay
home until at least eight o'clock."
- "If you're not home, then
I'll know you don't care enough,
and we can end it between us."
Wow, you hate to see it.
- This is a real love letter.
- [Little Lou] That's a real letter.
- May 2, 1962.
- [Little Lou] Holy crap.
- This is some good stuff.
The thrift store?
Yeah, let's go.
- Oh yeah.
All right, huge free chop D-Rock,
with stopping thrift
store, Saturday 10 to two.
Thrift stores are really
known for mug life.
We'll see what happens.
♪ They had a broken keyboard
I bought a broken keyboard ♪
("Thrift Shop" by Macklemore & Ryan Lewis)
- We made our way into a thrift store
so that we can find
really old Oscar the Grouch.
Oh no.
- [Mike] Christmas?
It's just haunting me,
(laughing)
there's so much.
Have a great day.
- You, too.
That was interesting, did
a little thrift storing.
Got a Power Rangers retro shirt,
a Mickey and an old
school Oscar the Grouch,
which I'm excited about.
You know, he's the mascot of Trash Talk.
- [Little Lou] What do you mean?
- Oscar the Grouch.
- Oh, really?
- Yeah.
- [Little Lou] Oh, that's right.
- Guys, we found our mascot.
Retro Oscar the Grouch,
Trash Talk baby, Trash Talk.
Mike, what do we got back there?
Show me that Power Rangers shirt.
This is an interesting.
- All right.
Yeah, it's gonna be interesting.
(upbeat hip hop music)
- [Man] Hey Garyvee.
- [Gary] What up, bro?
- [Man] What's up man, I'm
a big fan of your Instagram,
and whatnot, man.
- Thank you, brother.
I'm actually auction myself,
I saw your post last week man,
of the get out there,
- Yep.
get on eBay.
My family's been doing this for like,
50, 40 years of like, going out to yards
buying golds, so that's actually
what I'm doing right now.
- [Gary] Awesome, that's
gonna make it harder.
I was just about to start negotiating,
that dude blew up my spot.
God dammit.
Would you do five for these two?
- [Woman] Yes.
- Great.
Super Mario, mother fucker.
Some Disney stuff, Disney affinity.
For 3.60, feeling pretty good about this,
they wanted eight, they
didn't get it, they got five.
- For 25 a pop,
or three for 50 cents.
- White Castle, fuck.
This one, can't really find it,
and probably will throw
that one away or use it.
We got the OG White Castle.
- That's a big one.
- Right now, listed for 10.95.
- Yep, good score.
This is the banger, ready?
- Who's this guy?
85th anniversary of White Castle, sold
sold 17.95.
- Let's go!
Paid, literally,
- 33 cents.
50 cents for all three.
- 33!
This one right here, 17.95.
- Let's go, my guy.
- Mug life.
(laughing)
- Let's go!
- [Mike] Right, right, they got mugs?
- People are buying mugs like crazy, Mike.
(upbeat electronic music)
Going through our last
sale, see what happens,
then we're going back to the house.
Eleven twenty seven, just
an average day, but not bad.
We gotta really go through it,
we took some chances.
Verona overall was cold,
but Thomas the Train
at the 20 off the top.
- [Little Lou] Was higher.
- How much are the sweaters?
- [Woman] I think he wanted
10 for the sweaters.
'Scuse me Ralph, how
much are the sweaters?
- [Ralph] The sweaters are 10.
- 10.
Their name's Ralph. (chuckling)
- [Man] Excuse me sir, I
don't mean to disturb you.
- [Gary] How are you?
- I'm doing well.
- Good.
- [Man] I see you're.
- [Gary] Hustling.
- [Man] You're hustling right now.
- Nice to meet you.
Oh my god.
- How are you?
I'm doing great.
Is it possible we could
take a picture with you?
- [Gary] Yeah, for sure.
Why don't you guys look
around, let me do this deal,
and then I'll grab you on the way out.
Sir, what would do for this?
- [Man] Two cups, how about 50?
- [Gary] I was thinking a little bit less.
So the sweaters, you said, were 10 right?
- Yes, this is 30.
- Yep.
- [Man] That's 10, that's 40.
About 45.
- [Gary] What about 30
if I'm taking it all.
- [Man] 35.
- [Gary] Fair enough.
I'm hooked, right now.
This Giants stuff is worth a good amount.
Paid 35, he wanted 50,
feel good about it.
Give me five back, I'll take this.
- You got enough?
- Got enough.
All right guys, I wish you well.
Nice meeting you guys.
- Yeah, great to meet you.
- Take care.
- You're welcome, that was a huge score,
I hate the Giants with
all my fucking life.
But when you're fucking hustling,
and I'm trying to show
you guys how to do it,
I'll bend some of my rules,
I hate the fucking Giants.
I hate it, I hate what just happened,
but it's a fucking huge flip.
We hate the Giants. (laughing)
- Put this on.
- I can't, I hate the Giants.
I hate the Giants so much.
I have good news and bad news.
We had a huge score, it's
just a fucking Giants,
so this retro, wait 'til you see
what this sweater goes for, next.
Mug life.
All right, let's go.
Okay.
- [Little Lou] Hook a right.
- We're definitely gonna
go back to the house
where we feel like there's
some opportunities to strike.
But when we get there,
I have a funny feeling we're gonna see
that everything was taken,
right in our mouths.
Is this it?
(slow hip hop beat)
We're back and we're back.
- [Little Lou] This is nine.
- Nine?
Really?
- [Little Lou] It's right here.
- Christmas.
How much is this?
- [Woman] Bye bye, I don't know.
I'm sorry.
- No worries.
Probably a dollar.
How are you?
- Five dollars.
- Get outta here!
(laughing)
- Get out of here!
- Why did you come back, just for this?
- Yes.
(chuckling)
- A dollar.
- Thank you brother, great to see you man.
- Thanks guys.
- Stay well, buh bye everyone.
- [Man] So wait, tell me
what you guys do so I know.
- We do a show to show people
that you can go garage
sailing, and flip it
on Facebook marketplaces
and things of that nature.
- Oh cool, very cool.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] It's on YouTube.
- Okay, great.
- Awesome.
- Thanks man, take care, ciao.
I almost made the best piece of content,
I almost said we go around
and buy things for a dollar
that are worth nine, right in your mouth.
(laughing)
I almost said, he's the best.
That's it guys, great,
great coming to Verona,
great town, big ups.
Okayish day, I mean it's gonna be weird,
like we haven't gone through everything,
but there was no huge score.
The Thomas the Train thing
for 20 was probably a hundred.
There's some stuff, there's little cards,
there's stuff, there's some
mug life, there's some stuff.
Let's see if this guy
stepped up and found his.
- [Mike] Video games?
- Video games, he said he would.
Let's see if he comes through,
or he's gonna break my heart.
- How are you?
- You found 'em?
- [Man] No, I didn't find any.
- [Gary] No video games?
- [Man] No, sorry about that.
- No worries, brother.
Wow.
That was almost the end, D-Rock.
That was almost the end, boys.
(soft keyboard music)
This Tweet from the guy that I posted
about it not being as easy as it sounds,
and that's exactly right.
The reality is if this is your first day
and you're just learning,
you don't look up things properly
'cause you're searching eBay,
and you're not looking for
completed items or sold items,
you're just looking at
listings which throw you off.
You don't know about nuances
like red lines in Hot Wheels
versus just the black wheels,
so there's a million nuances
in every category of collectible,
and it takes time to learn.
Yeah, this is gonna take time,
at the same token, you
do have smart phones,
you can be diligent.
Again, what I'm really
focused on with this,
is you have time.
What are you doing in
those eight hours a day
that you're not working or sleeping?
That's Monday through Friday,
and then you got the whole weekend.
Obviously people work two jobs,
and there's a million variables,
but a stunning majority
of people have the time,
if you need an extra hundred
to a thousand dollars a week.
I believe this is real,
especially if you Google
town-wide garage sale
in your state or city, in your state,
and then drive a little bit.
Nothing's easy at first,
you know like working out
when you haven't worked out
for five years is not easy,
but then a week later it gets better,
and a month later it gets better.
I just don't know why
anything should be easy.
Easy is for losing.
(upbeat xylophone music)
(upbeat electronic music)
I paid 80 cents for these
vintage 1950's, 60's yearbooks.
All right, I'm here
with my buddy Mike Plyer
who helped me today.
Four Giants retro sweaters,
right?
A Ralph jacket, retro Giants,
if you're name's Ralph,
you're gonna want it.
I mean this is just all time,
this Giants cowboys hat, retro,
and some Giants mug life.
We paid 35 for it all,
pretty excited about it,
I think the sweaters and what have you,
can easily get to 60, 70, 80.
We'll see what happens.
(slow piano hip hop music)
♪ Sometimes I run fast
sometimes I run slow ♪
♪ It's the issues that I got in my brain ♪
♪ That let him know ♪
♪ Hey I know that's the best
thought I'm used to used to ♪
♪ I tried to blot the voices
out but they just get louder ♪
♪ Sometimes I hate that ♪
♪ It lets me to make rap ♪
♪ I'm just conversating about
my life and I'm a meg rat ♪
♪ What your box is full of
memories just take 'em ♪
♪ We been doing it for a
night but then I wake up ♪
♪ I can't control ♪
- I'm mug life.
Actually, this is remarkable.
This was $12.50, right?
- Yep.
12.50 on this.
♪ That I owe that ♪
♪ I've been sipping
ladies sipping vitals ♪
♪ I seen a lot of death it makes
it real 'til the fall out ♪
- I picked up this Dick mug for 50 cents,
with a capital D.
♪ Now why don't you come
inside see listen to survive ♪
♪ My people coincide side effects ♪
- I picked up these five Harley Davidson
retro T-shirt for 80 cents a piece.
♪ See listen to survive ♪
♪ My people coincide side effects ♪
- All right, I crushed this,
I got the Disney affinity
Xbox, Marvel, paid three for them.
They go for about five or six,
three to six a piece you said, Mike?
- Five to eight.
- Five to eight a piece?
♪ I rap through the pain ♪
♪ Liberty a factor remain ♪
♪ You coming for me get the sword ♪
♪ But at first it's a chain ♪
♪ Rapping talk a lot of
trash but I debt 'em ♪
♪ Toss 'em in the sandbox and forget 'em ♪
♪ Scowl I'm a psycho packing a riffle ♪
♪ Badder than Michael ♪
- Look all in all,
the Harley Davidson
T-shirts, the yearbooks,
Super Mario, we saw the Disney stuff,
little Oscar the Grouch, the plush,
the mugs, the Thomas the Trains.
I still think we get to
four or five hundred.
Let's go conservative, let's call it 300.
With the gas, with the eBay fees,
and it didn't go well,
and it's been five, six, seven hours.
Then it's gonna take
another 15, 10 to 15 hours,
if you're by yourself, forget
about my team doing it,
all the excuses, take them the fuck out.
Do you have five on a Saturday?
Do you have another 10 to
post, and pack, and ship?
Is that 15 hours worth,
the worst-case scenario, 20 bucks an hour?
For a lot of people, the answer's yes.
Not for everybody, but by the way,
every week's different.
Last year's two, three
Gs, this week's 300,
you keep grinding, you keep grinding,
you keep grinding.
I'm still not sure it's not gonna be 500.
The Giants shit is gonna go.
We'll see.
This was Trash Talk,
where I take people's trash
and turn it into cash.
♪ My mamma always told
must just to go for it ♪
♪ Every time they see me they say ♪
♪ Oh lord ♪
♪ It is what it is so why
you so mad at me last ♪
♪ So mad at me last ♪
♪ Why there so many rappers ♪
♪ That they all started calling me trash ♪
♪ They calling me trash ♪
♪ Wanna bad at least
somebody will end up dead ♪
♪ And the moral of this no ♪